der bahnhof im hessischen schwalmstadt
treysa hat seine besten zeiten längst
hinter sich seit jahren will die stadt
ihn barrierefrei umbauen und die
bahnsteige auf 55 zentimeter erhöhen
doch daraus wird nichts der grund die
bahn will künftig eine einheitliche
bahnsteig höhe von 76 zentimetern haben
viel zu hoch für die regionalzüge für
die bahnkunden in schwalmstadt ein
absoluter witz
es ist eine riesensauerei und es bedarf
gar keiner weiteren diskussion wenn man
diese sache angeht dann sollte man es
schon gleich so machen dass es auch
barrierefrei ist barrierefrei wäre die
bahnsteigkante in schwalmstadt-treysa
wenn sie 55 cm hoch wäre dann könnten
reisende problemlos in die regionalzüge
einsteigen
das jetzt alles auf eis liegt bedeutet
für rollifahrer dass sie weiter fremde
hilfe brauchen auf etlichen anderen
bahnhöfen ist das genauso
die bürgermeister im schwalm-eder-kreis
verlieren die geduld wir haben über
150.000 euro geleistet und haben seit
2011 auch in unseren haushalten jeweils
über eine million bereitgestellt wir
warten darauf dass es endlich losgeht
eine absurde hängepartie eigentlich
haben bund und bahn geplant die ideale
bahnsteighöhe auf exakt 76 zentimeter
festzulegen für einen gc prima aber für
den regionalverkehr eine katastrophe für
den wären 55 cm ideal
wir haben am züge die sind für 55 cm
bahnsteige geeignet für 76 zentimeter
bahnsteige gibt es keine züge die züge
sind für 30 jahre angeschafft und wir
können die jetzt nicht verschrotten das
wäre ein wirtschaftliches desaster
vergangene woche gab es zum thema
bahnsteighöhen wieder eine konferenz mit
dem bund den ländern und der bahn von
der deutschen bahn heißt es dazu es
wurde verabredet dass es weitere
gespräche zwischen db und den
bundesländern geben wird im anschluss
wird das abgestimmte konzept dem bund
noch einmal präsentiert mit anderen
worten es passiert erstmal gar nichts
nicht in schwalmstadt und auch nicht im
rest der republik
ich finde es auch eigentlich eine
frechheit dass das nicht so gehandelt
wird wie es notwendig ist es ist einfach
skandalös was hier mit menschen mit
behinderungen betrieben wird
ach ja ein paar kilometer weiter liegt
der marburger hauptbahnhof der ist
barrierefrei mit einer bahnsteig höhe
von 55 zentimetern und der wurde 2015
zum bahnhof des jahres gekürt das soll
noch einer verstehen